Researchers have developed a plant-like soft robot
that acts like a tendril,
lengthening its body to move through its environment.
They took their inspiration directly from
nature,
observing movement patterns in fungal hyphae,
brain neurons, and pollen tubes.
These organisms navigate their environments
not through locomotion, but apical extension --
growing through the tips of their bodies.
By controlling the direction of their growth,
they’re able to move through tight spaces
and form complex 3D structures.
This new soft robot can lengthen its body by 25,000%
at speeds of up to 10 meters a second --
comparable to speeds found in nature.
To achieve this type of movement in robot form,
researchers pressurized a thin membrane
of polyethylene plastic with a pneumatic pump.
The plastic is rolled into a spool
and can extend up to 72 meters.
Within the plastic tube, there are
small control chambers running along each side.
Inflating one chamber more than the other
allows the robot to steer through its environment.
Here you can see the robot steering itself
toward a light using a camera mounted at its tip
to sense the light’s location.
The robot can also form itself into 3D shapes,
such as a hook, allowing it to complete complex
tasks such as closing this steam valve.
And just like the roots of a plant,
the robot is able to move through tight spaces --
like dense soil.
In this example, the robot easily moves
between two pieces of sticky fly paper.
So far researchers have been able to demonstrate
the basic abilities of this type of robot on a single tube,
but in the future would like to implement
real-time branching behaviors
like those found in fungal cells.
This type of robot could potentially be used
in the future to fight fires,
assist in search and rescue operations,
and maybe even get you a sweet deal on a used car.